bridgehill signed with the minnesota
twins back in december he had already
been through
quite a lot over the course of his
15-year career
most recently it was the october
decision to go ahead with elbow surgery
a particular type of surgery he believed
would prolong his career
as opposed to ending his career and that
proved to be a very wise decision
because
here he is about to make his twins debut
when i look around
the league and and you see the the
pitchers that are
on the staff of the twins and in the
bullpen that quietly was one of the best
bullpens in baseball last year
and you know obviously didn't uh get the
credit that they deserved i believe
uh but you know now you look at it and
you look deeper and you go
deep into that that roster and it's uh
you know it's a world series team it
really is he'll try to be the third
twins pitcher to pick up a win in his
debut
so far so good one pitch one out mitch
hill is amazing
to me starting pitcher 40 years old
he throws two pitches basically he's got
a fastball
and a wonderfully wicked curveball
rarely he throws a change up and a high
fastball
and that puts edmond back on the bench
two down
popped up right field marwan gonzalez
near the line makes the catch to end the
first inning and a good
initial inning for rich hill on the
mound for saint louis it's daniel ponce
de leon
so he gets the call tonight with miles
michaelis done for the year he'll have
surgery
and ponce has been back and forth in his
cardinal career
starter reliever and back in the
rotation for the time being for the
saint louis cardinals
here is louis and a five-pitch want
and the rise who in his rookie season
had an on-base percentage of
right around 400 is aboard cruz the
american league cleaner of the week last
week
that's to right center field and down
for a hit headed for the gap
cruz delivers with a rise coming around
third
another big two out hit for the twins
they got a low fast ball at 94. and
just drilled into right center that
split grip he says
makes him feel like he hit the big end
of the bat to a good fastball a little
bit better
one's a tough time making any contact
against daniel ponce
de leon driven to right field rosario
lifts one up
and gone a home run rosario's first of
the year and it's two to nothing
well it was only a matter of time before
we started seeing some real rosario
stuff
that's right in that man's wheelhouse he
takes off on three and two
and ball four ponce de leon and i think
molina two thought it would be strike
three
so the twins get a walk and ponce de
leon really disappointed and that's
gonna be
the last pitch he throws so with the
twins leading two to nothing and two on
two out tyler webb
will try to get alex savile dump to left
and down for a hit cave around third
he'll score and avila comes through
it's three to nothing didn't hit it well
but didn't have to
and webb gives up a base runner and it's
a big one
protecting against that curveball the
ball got in on everybody's strong big
and strong enough to muscle the ball
into left field so now it's a
three-nothing lead for rich hill
facing the bottom third of the cardinal
lineup and now here he is
in the season's fifth game and he's got
four shutout innings
breaking ball tap back to the mound hill
runs it halfway there one away
high fly to left field rosario
he might have lost it for a while but he
made the catch this is a tricky
time not just here but in a lot of
ballparks no double digits
every inning that's what you want isn't
it
that's very economical on the ground
polanco charges fires on the run good
play
and another one two three inning for
rich hill
the 2020 debut of twins closer
taylor rogers trying to pick up a save
and a three-run lead
for the twin and he'll face the top of
the st louis lineup
two and two to wong then edmond and
goldsmith
off the end of the bat a spinner to
donaldson
and in time to get the speedy wong one
away and that'll bring up tommy edmond
and it's own two breaking ball puts him
away
two down that'll bring up goldschmidt
importantly with the bases empty
ten pitches into his season he's got two
quick outs
finally getting into a ball game and
he's on the verge of making very quick
work
of the cardinals in the ninth inning wow
wow
so the twins make it three wins in a row
now a little two-game sweep over the
cardinals